um I would love to talk to you about
this analogy of the symphony and the
reason why I'd like to talk to you about
this analogy is because the unity of all
being is the symphony infinite
consciousness is the symphony it is the
the the the this the seemingly or the
illusory which is that it does it's the
way that it appears is is as it can can
lead people off from the from the truth
so it's not as it appears that the
symphony has a good analogy in the sense
that and I want to hear what you think
about this
there's the unity of all being
but then there's there is this again
this illusory this the this the self
this Alan and Rupert and all of these
eight billion seemingly individuals but
part of the beauty of the symphony
analogy is that people don't reside in
the ultimate which is okay non-duality
excellent and rather it's both you the
unity it's non-duality excellent and
it's also I get the opportunity to be
and we get to be artists right we get to
we get to make great studio pottery
right we get to make great content we
get to engineer we get to design we get
to tinker but we do that all from the
place of unity we do that all from the
place of non-duality is that about right
how does that resonate yes ultimately
everything absolutely everything comes
from or is an expression or modulation
of consciousness or awareness I use the
words
synonymously some of our thoughts and
feelings and our subsequent activities
and relationships are mediated through
the belief I am a temporary finite
separate self so even though those
thoughts and feelings and the activities
and relationships that they generate
ultimately come from consciousness they
do not express the
what is true of the nature of
consciousness or reality why because
they are filtered through the belief in
separation and therefore Express that
belief ultimately of course they still
come from the same place that everything
comes from so I would suggest that true
creativity as any could could be said to
be any form be that forming in words and
music in any odd form is is a form that
comes unmediated directly from our
deepest reality or being that is not
filtered through the sense of separation
although it requires the agency of the
person to articulate that expression the
the source of that expression doesn't
come from a person that the feeling of
being temporary I know it is an
expression of the reality that lies
behind so to speak the the finite mind
or the separate person and and which is
one of the artists calls themselves a
channel so often yes
yes and and and the purpose of this art
that that is informed by the background
of awareness is to bring the truth or
the reality that is inherent in it out
into the world in order to be shared
with humanity yes yes and in that this
is the idea that I may be a
a violinist but you may be a saxophone
player and there is also a drummer and
there's a cellist and there's the
clarinet and that's the idea of and
they're all and by the way two clarinets
are maybe playing different harmonies
and so there's that as well so that's
the idea that all eight billion are in
that sense our artists in the symphony
and that they have their you they have a
unique expression yes I'm going to go
ahead yeah can I upgrade your metaphor
please upgrade it yes because your
metaphor is is is it's a beautiful
metaphor and and it's true I can see
what what you're trying to articulate
but the the first metaphor that you
referred to the metaphor of the dream
has I think is more efficient and is
clearer so okay can i if we want you can
go back to the the symphony but can I
really what you're saying
in terms of the of the dream metaphor
because I think it's much easier to
speak about and much easier to
understand so as you said in your
introduction take what happens to us
when we have a dream at night we where
are you where are you located now and
where do you live in South Dakota right
now you're in the code okay so say say
and you fell asleep in South Dakota and
you imagine that you're walking on the
streets of London you don't view the the
dreamed streets of London directly from
your mind asleep in South Dakota your
mind has forgotten that it is dreaming
it has overlooked itself and your own
mind has located itself within its own
dream you now seem to be Alan walking on
the streets of London that is the only
way your mind can perceive the dream by
overlooking itself locating itself in
the dream and
what is in fact its own activity from
this localized perspective in the dream
as the streets of London now everybody
else that you encounter on the streets
of London which from your limited
perspective seem who seemed to be
separate people are in fact the activity
of your own indivisible mind when you
wake up in the morning you realize the
entire dream all the different people
and all the different objects were the
activity there were no entities there it
was all the activity of my own mind it
only appeared as a multiplicity and
diversity of objects themselves from the
illusory perspective of the self that I
seemed to become in the dream now let's
say that you now you meet one of these
people you meet an old friend on the
streets of London in your dream you
haven't seen his friend for a long time
you both go to a cafe you sit down and
you have a conversation about something
and you both disagree what you're
talking about American politics okay and
you completely disagree with your friend
about so you you you you have one point
of view your friend has another
completely point of view so your point
of view you you each have a series of
thoughts you think that your thoughts
are right you think your friends
thoughts are incorrect but but so you
can have two completely different
thoughts opposing thoughts that seem to
be completely opposite to each other and
are indeed in the dream opposite to each
other when you wake up you realize that
both the true thoughts and the untrue
thoughts were generated in your own mind
and that goes for the the present
sensations the unpleasant sensations the
kind thoughts the unkind thoughts the
loving feelings the unloving feelings
the behavior that is intelligent and
loving the behavior that is cruel and
unjust it all ultimately is the
activity of a single universal mind yes
yes in so in the analogy the idea then
is that infinite consciousness has
within in the symphony has take we we
are we the all the artists in all the
seemingly individual artists have the we
we have a filter the filter of the the
mind in the dream that then is we that
there's there's a process of realizing
for the the the fight the seemingly
finite minds to realize that ah aha the
infinite consciousness and and and it's
both a ha the infinite consciousness and
it is also that it's not a ha ok and but
it's but it's aha
and so it's the realization and it's the
creation from that place of realization
so then declare the clarinet player the
violinist
etc they create their melody harmony
from that place of AHA and yet exactly
let's keep both metaphors alive so let's
let's take there are essentially two
possibilities let's go back I'm going to
translate what you've now said into the
dream metaphor you're back on them by
the way Rupert I just want to say I
think this is so powerful for the
synthesis of east and west because
though the East is very on the non-dual
and the West is very on the individual
and which is very interesting because
then it can synthesize them into that
let's go back to the and the dream
analogy you meet your friend so you you
you you you other dreamed character that
let's continue to call you Alan
and your friend his calls let's say he's
called David so Allen and David are
talking in the cafe so let's say that
that Allen has recognized that the the
essential nature of his mind the
essential nature of himself is shared
with everyone and everything although he
Allen still perceives from the localized
perspective of his body he can only see
the streets of London from where he's
sitting on his cafe table but he knows
that the nature of that which perceives
in him is not limited to located in or
generated by his body so he knows that
although he seems to be a separate
individual what he essentially is is
shared by everyone and everything and
his thoughts and feelings and his
subsequent activities and relationships
are informed by this understanding now
David does not realize this Allen's
friend of David believes it here Ian's
friend David reasons with himself well
every time I close my eyes the world
disappears every time I open my eyes the
world of the streets of London in this
case they reappear so it's perfectly
obvious that whatever it is that
perceives the world must live just
behind my eyes in my brain and was
obviously generated by my brain it is
limited to my brain and my brain dies my
consciousness will die with it in other
words David believes that he is a
temporary finite self that is separate
from albeit related to everyone and
everything else and all his thoughts and
feelings were almost all his thoughts
and feelings and his subsequent
activities and relationships are
informed by that understanding so Allen
and David have very different kinds of
thoughts they're different instrument
players in that sense as well if one
player is playing well they're different
they're different instruments but what's
more important is that the understand
that is expressed through the
instrumentality of each of their bodies
is a different understanding although
ultimately it is all the activity of
Alan asleep in South Dakota nevertheless
in one case that the in the case of Alan
in the dream that his thoughts and
feelings express the reality and in
David's case that they they do not
express that they express separation and
as a result of the belief in separation
David is able to not only think and feel
but act and relate in the ways that are
not consistent with truth love yes and
to extrapolate now for it from David if
you were to take David's point of view
in extreme cases one whose thoughts and
feelings and subsequent activities and
relationships are informed by this sense
of separation is able to commit acts of
gross unkindness and injustice they are
still the activities of the same
infinite yes
mind but filtered through the sense of
separation they are able to behave in a
way that is not consistent with reality
as yes Alan's in the dream does
everything he says he is an artist and
the purpose of his art is to express his
understanding and communicated and share
it just as that is the case with Alan in
real life it's so this is playing so
beautifully so the the ultimate dreamer
of infinite consciousness dreams up the
dreams up the the illusory universe in
the sense that it's it doesn't it's not
they doesn't seem to be exactly what did
what it is what yeah hold that thought
just for me again go I'm sorry I don't
like to interact but I want to I wanted
to say this the last time you yes please
the illusionary world I think this is
this is very important you're something
that I'm misunderstood for years and I
think it's something that causes a lot
of people who would otherwise be
interested in these matters and trouble
and for good reason
with this approach in and that is
because this the world is referred to as
being an illusion and for many people
the idea that something is an illusion
is tantamount to saying that it is not
real so I want to make a very clear
distinction between something that is
not real and something that is an
illusion yes
so that just let's just use an example a
square circle try to imagine now a
square circle or in the Zen tradition
the one hand clapping okay but let's
yeah let's stick with that try to
imagine now as a square circle we can't
do it in other words it's not even
possible to imagine the illusory image
of a square circle a square circle is
not an illusion it is utterly
non-existent however when we are
watching a movie for instance and we see
a landscape in the in the movie the the
landscape is obviously an illusion but
it is not non-existence there is
something that is there there is a
reality to the illusionary landscape and
of course when we go up to it we touch
the landscape we find relatively
speaking that it's reality is the
screens green yes all of this the world
as you rightly say from this in this
perspective the world is an illusion not
in the sense that it is not real it is
absolutely real in the sense that it is
the world is an illusion in the sense
that it is not what it appears to be it
appears to be a multiplicity and
diversity yeah objects themselves only
from the limited and localized
perspective of a separate self or a
finite mind yes yes this is gonna play
beautifully so that was very much you go
back to your thought about the user
is that that was very important Rupert
thank you so the ultimate dreamer of the
infinite consciousness we have this
dreams this the this the illusory which
is it's not what it appears to be
Symphony and then here's here's what
we're I'm really interested in this
symphony the symphony has the the these
these eight billion seemingly again
illusory in the sense it artists that
are individual that are being filtered
through the finite mind and that but
here's here's something interesting
my understanding of of of infinite
consciousness I think and I think it was
um Ananda Krishna Menon who said that if
you do have to think of it in a sense
you can think of it as behind behind
behind you
the infinite consciousness and that the
the more that you go through the process
of self abidance so you go through Atma
vichara self inquiry to gain the
realization of infinite consciousness
and then you have the process of self
abidance
so the idea is that you have potentially
varying degrees of artistry in the sense
that there are people that have deep
self abidance in infinite consciousness
so when they're playing their violin
they're doing it in as in the acronym st
oh service to other so they're playing
their violin with service to other
because they're there they've they've
realized that versus maybe a clarinet
player who in the case of david in your
dream remember so this is where we can
connect the two analogies david in the
case of the dream hasn't went through
the deeper self inquiry and self
abidance process and so he is under more
of the acronym of ste s service to self
so he is playing the clarinet but that's
why he's also going through the process
of seeking objects relationships
substances all these external things to
make himself happy and peaceful so how
is that where I think I feel like we're
getting closer to an interesting
synthesis between yeah dreaming for me
is it do you see the spectrum also in
terms of the a billion and do you see
them evolving as well in the sense that
someone that is service to self
inevitably Rupert we had slavery and we
don't have slavery anymore in much of in
much of the world and so there is an
sort of ethical or consciousness or
awareness it not in a sense that that
consciousness or the awareness is
evolving but our ethics and our morals
and our philosophies are evolving to be
more towards service to other and more
towards the unity towards that truth of
the infinite consciousness